γιοργό θαχιλέως που ακόμήε σταμάτησε αλλά είναι και αυτός ησε μεγάλικαι αντονισνικολάϊδης στης κοποπολύ κι
αυτός τετα αυτός το κτό που θα μπορούσα πιστεύω πολύ πιο εύκορα να γνωρίσουν κάποιο
που έχει την προπτινίτο τα λέντο για τι το δίωσαν αυτή και ίνα υτό ότι
δεν αξιοποιούνται με τον καλύτερο δινα τον τρόπο ατιας στα επόρα της αχονιά θα μπροσεν
εγώ να να ποτειά αυτά τα παιδιά σνιστείο πλοίαντοράχιστόν που ενα τα θημα ότι η
επιστεύο έχουν προπτικήεπεντή σε πάνο τους κετάλιπα και αυτό τον τρόπο σίγουρα θα θα να
πολύ πυ εύκολο να ενοπίσουν τα ανειρά τους πάντοτε στον αρθητισμό μιλάμε για χρήματα και
ότι η αλήχειαποτέ δεφτάνα αλλά δεν είναι μόνο τοπο α χρεματα νκή δίνεο που καντροπόζητα
τα διαγειρίζες διατί είμάστε μια μικρή χώρα και είναι υτόνόιτων ότι σε κάποια παράνα δεν
μπορούμε να να γωνιστούμε τα μεγάθυρια ίσως να πρέπει να επιλέξουμε στα θήματα που θέλουμε
να επενδίουμε πρόσβατα έίχα πάει στην αρχιανόληνπία στο συίναιτριον ου κάνενο ψάτεκοιμουκαι ένασα πόυ τους
ομιλητες ένα θα άλλος ομιλίο της ομός εδείξε μιαν έρευνα που είχε κάνει και στου
ία μιλίούς ε γιτην ελλάδα τέ αν θέλει να συνεχίσει να φέρνει μετάλια πρέπει να
να εα συγκεντρώσει της επενδύσητη της σε κάποια συγκεκριμένα αθχήμάτα βάσει το νποδομό βάση τουπεριβάλλοντως
καιτης χώρας υποδομέσαι περιβάλλο α μιλήσουμε και αχι του πλάνια θα λασάν είναι γ ραιά
αστενιζίτες έχουμε κερικές χαι θηκες στέλειας ρα αυτό να βευτίαστραβάει και λέγει παιδιά ενδείκνεται να
επεντήσουμε στηνί στο επλογία και να πάρει ακόμα μερικά θρήματα και να επικεντροίείς πάνωε ατά
πορέίνα κοδα άδικο προς τα επολύβα αλλά πέρα κανείς ι επιλογή το τι θέλει να
εακαταφέρε ετίς να καταφέρεις ναφέρνει σε ολημτακά μετάλλια τότε αυτς ίνοτου θέλεια απλά να βάλειςπολύς